raishin I really thought this was
interesting in the intellectual dark web
is a really good example of this which
you are a main pillar of in my opinion
so let's say that two people are having
a conversation and they're reducing
their points they're maybe keeping it to
a straight binary we see a lot of
political polarization that's occurring
today in the United States politics
finding a lot of the beauty and the
nuance of conversation when you take
complex position and you maybe stay
economists rather than become agitated
all of these things tend to drive better
conversations and it seems as though
you're leading that forefront what what
what do you see in that sort of path
that we're walking of figuring out how
to have better conversations
there's a I write about this affair
twelve rules for life there's a chapter
I think it's chapter nine I think that's
right
assume that the persons that you're
listening to know something you don't
it's kind of a derivation of some of
some things that I learned from Carl
Rogers
who was a great clinician great 20th
century clinician his star sort of rose
during the 1960s he was a humanist
here's a Christian missionary when he
was a kid but he dropped out and he
became a leading light humanistic
psychology and he was really interested
in the preconditions for buta
conversation and he thought that well if
you were going to engage in the process
of therapy with a client that the client
had to bring to the session before he or
she arrived the willingness to make
things better that would be the first
thing yeah right so that and I've done
therapy that was court-mandated like I
wouldn't recommend that that just
doesn't work very well
you know because you can't force someone
to be better they have to kind of come
already thinking that there's a bunch of
things they don't know and that their
life could be better than it already is
that's a good position to take when
you're engaging in a conversation with
someone it's like look if you already
know enough
more power to you man you know but if
you're suffering more than you think is
necessary which is like highly probable
or more than you think is desirable
which basically means if you're
suffering more than you think is
desirable that means that you're way
more ignorant than you need to be right
that's what it means because maybe you
have an illness you don't know how to
cure it yeah maybe you're having a fight
with someone you don't know get out of
it
maybe you're failing at work and you
don't know what to do about it's like
you're ignorant and no wonder because
people are ignorant and so you might
think well unless everything is just the
way you want it to be then you have
something to learn and then you think
well maybe the person you're talking to
no matter how
uncomfortable you are with their
opinions and how bent out of shape you
think they are maybe even how bent out
of shape they actually are there's
always the possibility that if you
actually engaged in a conversation you
ask them questions and you tried to
figure out what they thought
that you come away with one crumb of
knowledge more than you had when you
went into the conversation and like
conversations like that are a lot more
interesting
God founded my you know I've probably
done 20,000 hours of clinical work
something like that and so that's 20,000
hours of really really really really
serious conversations and they're almost
always interesting beyond belief and
like I've had clients that's I told you
already that sort of spanned the entire
spectrum from people who were so
impaired cognitively and behaviorally
that while they were utterly
unemployable by any any reasonable
standards to people who were
unbelievably high-functioning and I
found working with all of them if I if
I'm in the zone properly it's
ridiculously fascinating yeah because
people are ridiculously interesting and
so and and everyone has their own
characteristic experience that's
actually unique and so if you have a
real conversation with someone and they
tell you what's unique about their
experience the probability that you can
learn something from that is but it's
certain that you can like my low IQ
clients god they taught me so much it's
just they taught me how difficult things
were first
because to see someone struggle with a
task that the typical person can do
without even thinking sheds light on
exactly how amazing it is that that
normal people can do that and how hard
it is when when you were impaired to the
point where those sorts of normal
behaviors become become impossible it's
so enlightening it teaches you a lot
about the world and so I think part of
the reason that YouTube is killing
television is partly because it's
technologically advantageous I mean make
no mistake about it there's nothing that
TV can do that YouTube can't do and
there's a whole bunch of things that
YouTube can do the TV can't so it's
obvious which one's going to win but
what's also interesting about it is that
there seems to be a massive and
relatively untapped market for actual
conversation and it's because
conversation is
people of goodwill we're trying to tell
the truth we're trying to aim it making
things better is unbelievably valuable I
mean at least in principle that's what
we're all doing here right I mean yeah
even though you know you guys aren't
talking um that doesn't mean this isn't
a conversation you know it's first of
all we're trying to pay attention to you
at least enough to see if everyone's is
engaged in the conversation if you're
not engaged in it then it would be
completely pointless right and you're
involving them in your experiment that
was amazing
well one of the things I learned in my
clinical practice is that if the
conversation wasn't interesting then I
was doing it wrong
yeah it's rights just because